I would ask that we now pause for a
moment of silent remembrance students
and staff at the University of
California Santa Barbara remembering the
victims of America's latest mass
shooting a community still struggling to
accept that the gun violence that has
devastated so many other places in
America has reached them here we
remember the joy and a light they
brought to this world their
contributions to our University will
never be forgotten how to do that is an
issue paralyzing and dividing America
Richard Martina is the father of one of
the six dead Chris Martinez has blamed
the country's all powerful gun lobby for
the killings he read statements on
behalf of some of the families of those
killed it's time to stop the gun
violence our children deserve a land
free from fear son you will live in our
hearts forever and ever if you agree
that the people in Washington should
hear that not one more person should
have to die because of this ridiculous
situation then when I raised my hand I
want you to shout so loud that they're
going to hear you are you with me not
good enough one more time are you with
me not one more elliot rodger is just
the latest young American with mental
health issues able to arm himself and
carry out a mass shooting although he
did so after posting this video vowing a
day of retribution his victims just the
latest in a long line of others gunned
down on the streets and colleges of a
country apparently incapable of stopping
an epidemic of gun violence here are the
names of the six members of our
community as we remember them Jorge Chen
Catherine Cooper
James Hong Christopher Ross Michaels
Martinez David Wang Veronica
Weis majority of Americans want improve
background checks and other curbs on gun
violence they're politicians many of
them financially beholden to America's
gun industry have so far failed to
translate that shift in public opinion
into tighter gun controls Dominic
Waghorn Sky News Washington